I have to ask you about Melvin and
Howard obvious for obvious reasons but
the other big thing about that one is it
upsets me how inaccessible that movie is
like it's very difficult to find a copy
of him no I know I'll tell you why and I
and I love Universal I write music for
Universal but Universal at the time when
that movie was made by the great
director Jonathan Tommy and written by
the great screenwriter beau Coleman it
was it came out and it was like the only
reason anyone ever saw that movie were
was because of the critics you know when
people like badmouth critics I always
think I wouldn't have a career without
them because that movie no one was going
to see because Universal buried it they
couldn't figure out how to sell a movie
about a guy the story is about the
milkman who was a part of the Mormon
Church and he he claimed to be the heir
to the Howard Hughes fortune and the
reason he claimed that is that he
claimed that he picked up this is his
truth a true story
he he picked up Howard Hughes in the
middle of the desert after a little
motorcycle crash that Howard Hughes did
had and he took him to the back of his
hotel avidians and he gave him all the
change in his pocket not knowing it was
Howard Hughes just knowing it was some
poor old guy that needed help and that
while they were in the car they sang a
smelvin had written this song and he got
Howard Hughes to sing his song and and
that that was made him so happy
and then when Howard Hughes died there
was a will that said that listed all
these people this is before the age of
computers or personal computers where
Melvin could have looked up these people
or researched it or figured this out it
was written in a type of ballpoint pen
how he's like to write with but then Ben
kind of he bought up and it had been
discontinued and it's that one 17th of
my fortunes Melvin Dummar of gaps Nevada
along with a whole lot of other names
and the other names were like I think
for the most part either business
friends or variable you know obscure
relatives and things like that
and I saw the will and it was hard to
believe that wasn't true it's just hard
to believe having met Melvin that that
he would have had that anyone would have
had the ability to have done that at
that time and and pulled that off and so
anyway we told his story and the people
surrounding Howard Hughes weren't all
choked up about it because they didn't
want to believe in legitimacy of that
well and then Universal got it and I
don't know if they were pressured about
it I've never known that but they
certainly didn't know how to sell the
movie about this what they deemed a kind
of loser and so they just dumped it and
they didn't release it in Europe it got
no release in Europe for years I would
have people say can you please tell us
how we can see it and I was like I have
no idea I feel bad about the way that
I've seen it it's not an appropriate way
but you can find not super clear
versions on YouTube but you know that's
that's the kind of movie where I would
buy like an elaborate blu-ray with tons
of behind the scenes story and I want
all the details and we can't get them
well somebody needs to do it you're
absolutely right and I wish we would
have done it while Jonathan was alive
but just out of respect for him because
yeah Jonathan Downey was one of the
great American
filmmakers and I cherished every single
second working with him I worked with
him twice also in the movie Philadelphia
but yeah I it's really a strange thing
is it's like it's like the the world
conspired against this beautiful little
movie and it is it's an absolutely
beautiful little work of art are there
any specific memories from making that
movie that you find yourself we're
calling often we were doing this scene
where I'm getting remarried to Melbourne
and we don't have enough money to pay
for the little place in Vegas or Reno or
wherever it was
but I'm very pregnant and so we we
volunteer to be witnesses to other
peoples weddings and we kiss them and
stuff in and be the witnesses until
we've done enough that we make enough
money that we can actually get married
to each other and that was a strange day
because I've never kissed so many people
in one day there was guys and that was
strange but the thing I remember most
about that day is that when I was
sitting in makeup it was toward the end
of the shoot and and we were we're not
really welcomed there because of this
whole controversy about Howard Hughes
and everything so we weren't staying in
the nicest hotels and it had been a long
hard shoot and and I was in makeup and
and and Jonathan came in through the
door in the makeup trailer and he had on
this like pinstripe suit with a big
carnation in the look hell and I said
where are you going
he said nowhere and I said
what are you so dressed up for any guess
you're getting married today and he that
was his direction to me that day he
didn't give me another direction that
day he just dressed up for my wedding
and that was the magic of Jonathan's and
me that he it was like from the second I
saw him and he told me that it was like
I had all the energy in the world there
were no problems it was like what a what
a blessing to be able to do this scene
today you know that's that's what he
brought out in